there are seven secret passageways out
of the castle we'd recommend
this one if muggles spotted hogwarts all
they would see
are old ruins and signs warning them to
keep out witches and wizards are skilled
at keeping their magical lives private
but we happen to know all of their best
secret entrances and hidden passageways
here are all the ways magical folk get
around unnoticed
can we find all this in london you know
where to go
diagon alley was our first introduction
to the world of magic
located behind the leaky cauldron pub in
london
hagrid just has to tap the five bricks
around the hole in the wall with his
wand
in this case his umbrella to gain
entrance in the books it's slightly
different
you tap the brick three up and two
across three times
then you're granted entrance to the
greatest wizarding market in all of
london
a magical shopaholic's favorite place
don't worry harry we'll explain
everything when we get back to
headquarters
number 12 grimmeld place in london is an
order of the phoenix safe house and one
of the coolest hidden places in the
entire wizarding world
the house is protected by a fidelious
charm with albus dumbledore as secret
keeper
to gain entrance the secret keeper must
have told you the location
or written it down for you the house
seems to inflate
between house numbers 11 and 13 with no
muggle the wiser to the earth-shaking
appearance of a secret wizard hideaway
i've never used the visitors entrance
before should be fun
while arthur and harry have to do some
very muggle commuting to get to the
ministry of magic's entrance
their journey into the ministry itself
is very
magical and pretty well hidden to enter
you have to find the old red telephone
box
step inside and dial 62442 you must
state your name and business for the
operator before being given a silver
visitor's badge
and then descending into the ministry
like you're in an elevator
we flush ourselves here the employees
entrance though
is decidedly less glamorous when harry
ron and hermione
infiltrated the ministry they weren't
exactly excited to find out that
flushing themselves down a toilet was
the only way to get inside and stand or
cover
but all these hidden ministry entrances
make sense
the ministry is one of the wizarding
world's best kept secrets
but it's also where the secret keepers
work in the ministry of magic's
department of magical accidents and
catastrophes are the obliviators
wizards who are particularly skilled in
memory charms and who are always busy
cleaning up magical messes and modifying
muggle memories
seen by no less than seven muggles
the room of requirement itself is one of
hogwarts many mysteries
but this hidden room also has its own
secret passageway
when dumbledore's army was hiding out
there they found that their hunger
inspired
a secret door to hogsmeade to open up
right behind a picture of ariana
dumbledore
aberforth dumbledore could not open the
passage from his side when people were
using the room
but he could send ariana's portrait to
summon members of the army when in need
i don't remember this other orders man
that's because it never existed till now
hogwarts has a magical infirmary but the
real serious magical conditions get
treated
at a wizarding hospital that was sadly
left out of the movies
saint mungo's hospital for magical
maladies and injuries is
first mentioned when arthur weasley gets
bitten by nagini
harry ron and hermione eventually make a
visit where they run into neville and
his grandmother and learn for the first
time what happened to neville's parents
the entrance to the hospital is an old
department store in london
a wizard has to approach the glass
window and speak very quietly to the
ugliest dummy dressed in a green
pinafore dress
the dummy will nod and then you can step
through the glass and into the hospital
i was wondering if you could tell us
about the chamber of secrets
the chamber of secrets was once a
well-hidden hogwarts mystery that
allowed the basilisk to get around via
pipes
located in the first floor girls
washroom the entrance is marked by a
snake etched on a copper tap
you must speak parcel tongue to open it
harry chose to say
and then the tap will move out of the
way so you can slide down a large pipe
which doesn't look like much fun
when the only thing to cushion your fall
are piles of bones
the shrieking shack was supposedly
haunted but curious hogwarts students do
have one way to
access the building if they're brave
enough there's a secret passage under
the whomping willow
in the books crookshanks taps on a
specific knot on the tree's trunk which
freezes its branches
in the movie harry and hermione have a
less than graceful entrance
but they do eventually make it through
the hidden door i solemnly swear that i
am up to no good the marauders map is a
curious wizard's best friend when it
comes to sneaking around
unnoticed harry potter used one
particular passageway twice to get to
and from hogsmeade after george and fred
gave him the map
the one-eyed witch statue by the stairs
to the defense against the dark arts
classroom
can be opened by tapping the hump with a
wand and declaring
descendium it leads to the seller of
honeydukes and can be used again without
a password to return to the school
mischief managed according to the
marauders map
there are actually seven different
passageways into
and out of hogwarts but they're not all
easily accessible
sirius black an expert at getting in and
out of hogwarts unnoticed
once mentioned a passage located behind
a mirror on the fourth floor that was
large enough for an entire
organization to hold a secret meeting it
led to somewhere in hogsmeade
but apparently caved in in 1992
there was also a passage behind the
statue of gregory the smarmy
that fred and george found during their
very first week at school
even before they had the map filch who
always seems to be sneaking around the
castle
also knows about three other secret
doors and we're sure mrs norris does too
then what's he doing in bourgogne and
burke's browsing for furniture
to get from hogwarts to nocturnale draco
decided to use two vanishing cabinets
one of which was located in borgen and
berks the movie absent poltergeist
peeves
originally smashed one of the two
vanishing cabinets
after being convinced to do so by nearly
headless nick but the passage was
reopened when draco fixed the cabinet to
bring death eaters through
these vanishing cabinets are especially
secret because they don't even appear on
the marauders map
let the feast begin we got to see a few
magical kitchens at work in the movies
but we never saw the grandest kitchen
of all the hidden hogwarts kitchens
where house elves were always hard at
work preparing student meals
well when they weren't up to trouble the
kitchens are located behind a picture of
a giant fruit bowl
to enter you must tickle the huge green
pair in the picture
it'll giggle and then turn into a green
door handle this might be one of the
strangest
and possibly safest ways to enter a
hidden room in the entire wizarding
world
[Music]
the best way to get some magical help
might just be the night bus
which picks up a witch or wizard in need
and zips through busy traffic to
transport them
wherever they need to go without
worrying about being spotted by a
curious muggle
to hail the bus a witch or wizard must
stick their wand hand out like they
would to hail a muggle bus
though it's also possible to book
tickets in advance if you prefer to plan
ahead
this is the third floor it's forbidden
while the underground chambers where the
mirror of aeroset are kept
aren't exactly a secret dumbledore did
tell all the students to avoid the third
floor corridor and protect the door with
a not so subtle three-headed dog
they were definitely magically hidden
and a mystery for most hogwarts students
well except harry ron and hermione
because they can't resist a do not enter
sign
past fluffy the flying keys devil snare
and some high stakes chess
were the hidden rooms where harry faced
off with voldemort for the first time
since he was a baby
he's walked straight at the wall between
platforms nine and ten
platform nine and three-quarters located
at king's cross station is a perfect
example of wizards hiding in plain sight
if you're a witch or wizard you'll
notice the platform to hop aboard the
hogwarts express doesn't even exist in
the muggle world
and if you ask about it you'll just end
up confusing some non-magical folk
located between platforms 9 and 10 you
just need to run
straight into the brick divide and then
it's all aboard the hogwarts express
well unless something or someone cuts
you off
then you've just got a headache and an
angry owl if we can't get through
maybe mom and dad can't get back which
of these secret passages do you wish
we'd seen more of in the movies
if you were a hogwarts student would you
go hunting around the castle for secret
doors
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to tap that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
stuff
thanks for watching